>>> ELISE S LETTING. Y OFCHENEY.
S WAY MORE LAL
SHE HADE PLAY TO HRUMP FQU
STRENGTH LIE ECTIONHERE SHE IS
RADIO SHOW MERPROMISED TO ITE R
AUG ON IN ARIZONA WHERE
A GOVERNOR IS BEING ATTACKED BY
ELECTION
>> FULLY SPO AUDIT IA.
WE WANT TRANSPARENCY AND ANSWERS
FO PEOPLE.
WHAT ARE THE DEMOCRATS SO AFRAID
THE VOTERS IN ARIZONA AND THE
STONA PURSUE.
I T .
FUTURE. RECY IS  NEED TO FIX THO
S  ARIZO
AZA?RSTANDS.ALLY EXAMINING THE E
THERE ARE ANY TRACES OF BAMBOO
IN, BECAUSE ONOFCONSPIRAHES HOL
FAKELOTS WIP
REMEMBIS LLY
BYCANS.
AND BECAUSE S ONE OF
TH REPUBLICANS ILEADERSHIP WNGES
IS,HE
BEINPURGEDM HER POSITI.
N.OBLES ISE FROM
CAPITOL HILL. TSEGROUPSAYSTEFANE
ABOUT IT FNKKE.ERVATIVE GROVE OO
MED HOTHEYOT
CLUB FOR GX TION, WORRIED ABOUT
KINDF X IN
THIS IS WHSAID SHORTLY
LIBERAL,NEWS CAME OUT.
LIFETIME RATINURTH WORST IN
THE HO
HOUSRES A
CONSERVATIVE TO LEAD MESSAGING
AND WIHE HOUSE
OR GROWT AID
ORNI, BUTOLD
ARCO INTERNA WELL.HOUSE FREEDOM
HOUSLEADERSHIP, ALONG WITH
FORMER PRESI D
RUSHED T
THE T TO CHENEY.
THEY CAN SEE, JAKE, THERE'S
PROBABLY NOTHING THEY CAN DO
ABOUT TH STEFANIK IS
LIKELY TO BECOME NEXHO
CONFERENCE CHAIR.
T TO TALK ABOUHEUETQ TS, IMMIGRT
HAT  CONFEREE PUTTING OUT THE MF
SO .H TOF THAT REPUBLICAN PART
GANGEL.'S TALK TO S JAMIE
YOU HAVEEW REPORTING ABOUT
THIS TENSION THA I
STEFANTH TRUMP MORE OFTEN THANT
MATTER BECAUSE T'S ISSUHERE.
>>HEUE AND ERE'S ONE PERSONDONA.
THIS IL ABOUNA.
I SPOKE TO SEVER CONSERVATIVES
WHREANEY SAID LIEY
IS TRUCONSERVATI
AS RYAN HAS BETTER
RATINGS ACROSS THE-- 'S ALWAYS
>> NOT JUST O-TRUMISESTHE TTH
PR ABOUT THE
>>NDTERESTING IS SHEDERATE, BUE
ALONG TH OF HERS
SAID TO ME, SHE FIGU E D ONLY W.
SHE DID IT
I SAID, DOES SHE REALLY BELIEVE
IN TRUMP? POLITICALNCY?
, I HAVE
IDEA, BUT SHE'G ON T
HIM TIGHT.
>> A LOT OTO
WOHE BUSH WHE
HOE THAT.
>> CORRECT.
>>T ACT
OR SHE GOT AY.M JORDAN ALL BITT.
LISTEN.
>> Y CE PU
CONFERENCE
DEMOCRAT TALKINGK S A LITTLE  P.
FACTS ABOUE ELECTION ACATED  NT
GOVERNORS, STATE OFFICIALS,
FAAT'S A DEMOCRAG POIN
NOW?
>> NO,AYRE TO MET ? IS WAY BE
DN'T
THEY ARE COMPLETELY DOWN THE
RABBIT
EYG FORWARD.
IT IS CLEAR THAT DONALTRP HIS CE
IT SAID,LLNTERESTING ABOUT
DAYS IN OUR COALONP.
ANI THINK 'R
TODAY, NOT A PBEUSTHERE ARE PLE
AND  WHO A